Marvel has officially revealed their
phase for slate we now know the future
of the MCU how's it going everybody it's
Warren and let's not waste any time
let's get right into these movies so the
first movie that was officially
announced tonight was the Eternals and
of course we knew this one was coming
but now we know the official cast is
Angelina Jolie Richard Madden Camille
Nanjiani
Lauren red Liffe Brian Tyree Henry Salma
Hayek Lea McHugh and Dawn Lee the next
announcement for phase 4 it was the
Falcon and Winter Soldier series now of
course we knew this was coming as well
but they did announce the return of
Baron Zemo and then they announced
shang-chi and The Legend of the ten ring
so the real Mandarin is officially
coming to the MCU the cast for Shang
chief will be Somalia as shang-chi
Aquafina and tony leung they then
announced the Wanda and vision series
that I'll talk about in just a little
bit
they then announced the Loki series and
gave us a new logo and revealed that the
Loki series is going to take place right
after Loki gets the tesseract in 2012
and Avengers end game so it's going to
explore what he does after he gets the
tesseract and escapes then they
announced Doctor Strange 2 in the
multiverse of madness they also revealed
that the events that take place in the
Wanda and Disney Plus series will
directly connect with the events in
Doctor Strange 2 in the multiverse of
madness they then announced the Disney
plus what-if series and this will be the
very first animated series and they
confirmed that all of the MCU actors
will voice their own characters in the
animated series we then got an
announcement for the Hawkeye series and
they confirmed that he will be teaching
Kate Bishop then of course we got a
Black Widow announcement we knew this
was coming but it's nice to get an
official announcement for it then what
could possibly be the biggest
announcement of the night was that we
got a Thor 4 Thor love and thunder and
that is the reveal of the phase 4 slate
but there is more to come Kevin Feige
got on stage and he did say that black
panther 2 is coming Captain Marvel to
his coming guardians of the galaxy 3 and
Fantastic Four is confirmed and the
mutants are coming to the MCU so that's
the full phase 4 lineup that they gave
us including the announcement of the
Fantastic Four coming to the MCU and the
mutants
wanted to do this quick video just to
get it out so you know what phase four
is I'll do a complete full in-depth
breakdown soon don't forget about my
giveaway at 500,000 subscribers I'm
giving away Marvel Legends items and an
Xbox one or ps4 the winner gets to
choose to enter all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain you can also follow me on
Instagram I'm doing an Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway right now you can follow me at
cosmic war in 13 as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof